well good morning and I'm victor's ow
I'm the chancellor for Health Affairs
Duke University and chief executive of
the duke university health system now i
chair the session on health advantage
transforming competitiveness in asian
region and the topic we talk about is
really clearly health and health care
and so the critical we should understand
is this is a very important issue both
from a society perspective but also an
economic perspective if you look at
what's happening in this region a recent
study showed that sixty percent of
disease burden and deaths are related to
non cumin abul khair chronic disease or
NCD non-communicable chronic disease
that's obesity diabetes hypertension
arthritis and many others so instead of
thinking only about infectious disease
such as malaria TB dengue more and more
recognized that's important to reduce
and prevent these ncds these are
lifestyle and environmental issues such
as you know nutrition exercise tobacco
user cetera and the panel discussion is
very clear that everybody agrees that we
need to change government policy and to
create incentive to do more prevention
and to reduce future burdens of disease
there's also a big discussion about the
role of the business sector that is what
do employees have to do to enhance
wellness at the workplace and obviously
the healthy the employer the better is
the business so we had a long discussion
in the importance of workplace wellness
as an initiative but also I think
there's recognition that there's a whole
health and healthcare ecosystem that
involves everyone involves individual
and their own behavior involves our
schools community but also government
and also business and will cause health
care systems those who deliver health
care such as doctors nurses several only
by working together as one
focus on reducing the ncds can we
overall improve the health of a
community improve productivity but also
reduce or the overall financial burden
which as you know can make countries
insolvent if we don't solve the problem
of health care costs so thank you very
much it's been a great experience